this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
atrial fibrillation is a type of
arrhythmia which is an abnormality in
the pace or force of your heartbeat
if you have atrial fibrillation the
heart's upper chambers contract in a
fast twitchy fashion resulting in an
irregular uncoordinated heartbeat
your heart is a muscular organ made up
of four chambers the right and left
atria
and the right and left ventricles
during a normal heartbeat the chambers
of your heart contract and relax in a
rhythmic pattern
to deliver a consistent flow of blood
throughout your body
the right atrium collects blood from the
body
and the right ventricle pumps it to the
lungs which bring oxygen to and remove
carbon dioxide from the blood
at the same time the left atrium
receives blood from the lungs
and the left ventricle pumps it out to
supply your body's tissues with oxygen
and nutrients
each heartbeat begins in the heart's
natural pacemaker called the sinoatrial
or sa node located in the wall of the
right atrium
an electrical signal starts here then
spreads across both atria causing them
to contract and push blood into the
ventricles
as the atria relax the signal travels
through the atrioventricular or av node
to the ventricular walls
causing them to contract
the ventricles relax completing one full
heartbeat
immediately the sa node generates a new
electrical impulse repeating the pattern
in atrial fibrillation the electrical
signals originate from unusual locations
in the atria and nearby pulmonary veins
these abnormal signals travel through
the atria haphazardly causing the atria
to contract in a jumble of rapid quivers
and twitches
the signals bombard the av node causing
the ventricles to contract rapidly
even at a faster pace the ventricular
contractions cannot keep up with the
rapid atrial contractions resulting in
an uncoordinated heartbeat
after these irregular contractions the
chambers may not empty completely
when blood collects in the atria clots
may form
a clot can flow out of your heart
through your neck
into your brain
where it can cause a stroke
blood pooling in your ventricles
deprives your body's tissues of oxygen
and nutrients
if your heart is consistently unable to
pump enough blood to meet the body's
needs you can develop heart failure
your doctor may treat your atrial
fibrillation
with antiarrhythmic medications
antiarrhythmic medications control the
electrical signals sent to your atria
which help your heart beat in a regular
rhythm
after treatment your heart may still
beat too quickly
in this case your doctor may give you
beta blocker medications
to slow your heart rate down to normal
in addition your doctor may recommend
procedures that restore your heart's
normal rhythm and rate such as
cardioversion
ablation
[Music]
or pacemaker placement
in electrical cardioversion your doctor
will give your heart a shock to start a
normal heart rhythm
during ablation your surgeon will use
radio wave energy to destroy the heart
tissue generating the abnormal
electrical signals
in pacemaker placement your surgeon will
implant a small device under the skin
near your heart to regulate your heart's
rhythm
you